welcome to another session of Android
developer office hours i have with me
today Trevor Jones paranoid Alexander
Lucas who Joe Fernandez you know and I
am your leader Joe Allen let's start
right away with questions from the
moderator the first question is to avoid
the bitmap size exceeds vm budget error
we need to do a lot of extensive
low-level memory manipulation is there
any high level API that will let me just
point to the bitmap and do all the low
level stuff automatically all right so
the short answer is I don't think there
is one that I'm loved so for those of
you who don't know bitmaps an Android
are stored into memory in the Java heap
which is limited if you try and store
something too large you'll find that you
can very quickly run out of heat which
is why you recommend doing things I
agree you know making sure that you call
recycle bitmap when you're done with any
graphics fun things like that and also
making sure that you scale any images
are using before actually trying to
display them on the screen so if you
take something to say you know three or
four times sighs the available screen
space and trying to display that you
might find that you actually might not
have enough memory available for
graphics unfortunately I don't know
anybody's actually bringing the library
that takes care of the stuff
automatically if somebody out there does
want to go and write one and open source
it I'm sure a lot of developers will
thank you but right now i don't think i
have a prepackaged solution i can offer
missiny does no one feel free to hop on
to hangouts or Chad and let me let us
know yeah it's all right also you missed
something yeah anybody else to look we
do have a do-over
unless flag large heap that can be used
some it works sometimes a little it'll
solve the problem sometimes yes what if
a solution and more of material work
around really yeah but it'll it'll get
the job done the main thing to remember
about it is that it's not and it's not a
way to avoid doing proper manner memory
management if you have memory leaks it's
just going to increase the time before
you getting out of memory exception so
he's like a river is flooding young you
start throwing extra sandbags on it'll
it'll buy you a little bit of extra time
but there's still examined the mental
problems that you need to dress in your
code to go and avoid these problems yeah
great any other submissions I want to
emphasize that if you're online with us
in the Hangout and you've got a question
on you know raise your hand type it in
and we'll go to it as soon as we can the
next question and moderator is how do i
balance between high and low end devices
using a progress dialog in an async task
seems to make the high-end experience
worse because it's a quick blip that you
can't read not having that leaves the
low-end devices wondering what's going
on for the users I would assume the
low-end device is wondering what's going
on all right so there's basically a
progress bar that goes by so fast on a
high-end device right that that's all
that's not worth putting up it's an
interesting problem oh yeah this is all
promised unique to Android to you that's
a general you I problem right anywhere
you're developing right you're going to
have a set of higher end devices instead
of lower end devices but and the lower
end devices are always going to take a
little bit longer to do stuff and
sometimes higher and devices go so
quickly that you never actually even
notice that things are processing so in
that case I think the solution here is
actually not to use a progress dialog
and this I think it goes a little bit
beyond the problem you you're describing
here I honestly think they're ugly I
think a much better solution is to try
and build some indicator into you I to
indicate the things are still
ending so for for example SI i'm
building a twitter client but because
everyone loves to our clients right and
you want to go in this place of
notification well you're going and
fetching tweets you know the naive
approach is to go and pop up a big ugly
little progress dialog while you're
fetching data from the network and no
technically it's a correct solution but
from a uart perspective and as far as
your users are concerned it sort of
sucks because you can't do anything
while this dialogues on screen and you
know this is generally problem with any
modal dialog as you want to go and do
things even while you're going and
fetching data from the network or
whatever it is that your apps doing so
that's why most replies to find will
just go and put a little spin it up in
the action bar a little e a loading
symbol a lot of times we'll even go and
have like the other refresh button you
push their fresh bud and it swaps out
there a fresh button for a for example a
spinning or fresh button something like
that short version don't block your UI
while you're loading things and that
solves the problem any other comments
don't I would add that a progress bar is
usually used if you know exactly how
long something is going to take and if
it's not going to if you can calculate
that it's not going to take very long at
all based on the information available
to you um you may not want to display it
right but they still could be just
displaying engineer you know I increase
a spinning live and so I would agree
with Trevor that the the other option is
to display what's called an
indeterminant on progress bar or
spinning wheel which basically says
we're doing something and if it comes up
and then goes away immediately you're
fine or you could just display it for a
second or however long it takes for the
process to actually finish yeah and if
you really are adamant about displaying
some ugly modal dialog a solution to
this would be put in some hysteresis so
if it takes you know less than a second
don't do anything but after a second has
elapsed assume it will probably take a
while and put up that spinning dialogue
and if you really don't like the idea of
a dialogue appearing for you know a
couple hundred milliseconds and
disappearing because that actually serve
disconcerting you have users who look at
and go what the heck just happened you
know the hysteresis works on the other
end to you could say this dialogue must
appear for a minimum of save 500
milliseconds or you know a second and
yeah it sort of sucks because you're
making users wait when you're not
actually doing anything but it's
entirely possible that it actually might
lead to less confusion this is one of
those areas where it actually might be
useful to go and get some you know just
regular users off the street sit them
down and go and you know evaluate their
happiness see what you I works best but
in all these cases I think the better
approaches to do skip modal dialogues
entirely yeah okay if they were going to
do modal dialogues i would suggest
actually sort of a combination two of
the approaches that you suggested which
would be after like that say 200
milliseconds at that point track your
progress and say like fun 99% through
there's no point in putting up a
dialogue for a millisecond but if I'm
only ten percent of the way through it's
going to be like I was sufficient length
of the user going to see going to see or
want to see the dialogue and at that
point put it up that is if you decide we
still want to go the mobile dialogue
route in general I would agree with
Trevor suggestion of the Refresh icon
great thank you very much gentlemen next
question it would be nice if the Android
team could post the written answers to
the questions asked in the moderator so
that the people could quickly view all
the answers and even search to find the
answers as well that's an excellent
suggestion so we're good on with that
though is that means we have to go and
re-watch the entire video afterwards so
I'm instead of spending an hour every
week in here answering questions we're
not spending two hours mination to Daryl
prep time and that's time that we're not
going and building other things so I
think we'll have to find a creative
solution to this if anybody there are
you out there watching live wants to
volunteer and be a scribe maybe that
would be a good idea but yeah I think
just having us go and post them is it's
a great idea in theory in practice it's
a little tough to pull off we do record
them though right we did well we have
the this whole stream is record to
youtube so you can go through and
but yeah really there was something nice
about having text answers right yeah we
could tag the youtube video to at least
give you some hint of the types of
things that we've discussed on it that
goes back to the same problem that we
have to go and watch the stream again
and then it becomes another hour now a
little button we can push many jump to
each next thing that inserted a marker
that would make it a lot quicker well
that will have to experiment right if we
can find a good solution easy but I hear
you I agree we I think we just need a
creative solution to make it quite right
yeah it probably won't be a direct
written transcript to everything because
first of all that would take a lot of
time and second of all not all of the
things that we say are really worth
writing down and sometimes our answer is
we don't have an answer or sometimes our
answer is we can't come and comment on
that so that's probably a very little
used to write down but there's other
things that we could probably do that
would be useful so want to think about
it you could go and take our android
phones and just put it on on speech to
text mode and just have it go and
transcribe everything for us live I
think YouTube does that for you already
yeah you can do captions I'm not sure
how it all works yeah well usually ends
with rather hilarious results yeah
rabbits eat lettuce right okay so anyway
um that's our answer for the moment
let's move on to the next question this
is illegally in the Hangout week and ask
questions no one knows okay hey oh you
guys do you want to ask something be
sure to shout a bit right definitely
shot i'll be led we're a bit while
getting you know right anymore arms
really well but you have to actually my
advice if you want if you are watching
live and you want to ask a question post
something into the chat bar on vibrate
because our engineer robert is usually
pretty busy managing not only the
hangout but also the video and audio
streams for this so easiest way to get
noticed is just put up some chap saying
i actually want to ask a question and
held right care of you okay so next
question and moderator is in my country
to sell my app on the play store i need
an adsense account but for that i need a
website which cannot be a landing page
to an app that doesn't exist but my net
app needs an adsense account too
exists how do I solve this infinite loop
all right so low to sell the opinion
absence account right to have an adsense
account you need a website light but the
web all right short version what if you
put up a blog for your app or you just
put up a landing page saying coming soon
I can think of actually double check the
Adsense DLCs there you probably need
some content but even though your app
doesn't exist doesn't mean that you
can't put up something for that it's
okay i think for the app to exist the
the main the main thing is that if the
app exists but it's just on the play
store yet then it's a valid piece of
content to build a website for and then
once you have the site you can get the
adsense and then you upload it to google
play yeah you could also just you know
presumably you have a company of some
sort some entity that is actually making
this app and hopefully that entity has a
website so it doesn't necessarily have
to be your apps website it could be your
company website or your personal website
right you are another company i would
say the idea of having a blog website on
would be really good for a nap because
that allows your customers to give you
feedback and it allows you a quick and
easy way of giving people news about
what's going on with your app yeah easy
publicity right any other comments no
let's move on any chance of doing
another Android design hang out we're
making it a regular event the one you
had a month or two ago was really
helpful point noted I think that's an
excellent idea and I think we can find a
way to make that happen so look into it
for ya great Thank You Trevor the Friday
review guys do the little bit of a
design review as well they do do a
little bit i mean the focus isn't
necessarily on design but that is one of
the things they can better so for those
of you who've never tuned in before
every friday we have two separate
hangouts one with Ian and Dan and the
other with raid oh and I forgot who else
you she joins them but Dan in the in go
in review games and right okay yeah and
radio and Fred review apps and they
provide
dr. feedback on what could be better
what's good you know basically just go
and walk through the entire experience
of using these apps and help provide you
know either provide advice on what could
be better or point out what's really
good about it to go and serve as an
example for the developers so part of
that is a UI review so that also might
get you some additional feedback but you
know I think it's also it would be nice
to go and get Matias in here sometime
and have him there if not pretty at
least Roman may have some folks actually
go and just talk you I because that's
always an exciting event right agreed go
ahead John all right we can't hear you
um oh well okay so um what issue is
people can't yours on hang out be going
here youtube so he's homey and then you
can't hear what oh boy oh okay silly
yeah I get it so he's listening to
youtube but our speakers are not working
so check them otherwise either the
monitor slider on the soundboard Robert
make sure that the right slider is not
muted and the computer audio slider
which is two to the left is not muted
bear with us proud I still see an orange
light on the speakers that's not a good
sign me also the red knobs control the
volume going into the monitor bus this
is another reason not to transcribe
absolutely everything that goes on and I
know about you don't find this valuable
I think it's fascinating I think it's
fascinating i'm not sure whether it's
valueless you know it lost young people
out live to hear us I say you can just
go and pass the left over here and hold
on icon next to the computer might not
be a bad idea at this point the video
will get to um next question is HTTP
HTTP client interface
implementation is using the proxy
configuration but httpurlconnection does
not seem to use it can you explain this
behavior in more detail and there's a
link to a post on the on Google+
someplace so I can't explain the
behavior itself that's a very good
question i don't know why that is but i
can tell you that it's is HTTP client
that's part of the apache library is the
recommended approach and we have had
some blog posts that strongly advise
developers to go and use HTTP client
over your connection whenever possible
because that's what our engineers are
spending all of their time on so short
version you all connection is old and
busted HT client is the new hotness okay
highly technical term yes right right
and then that's probably be the case in
the future going forward to we're
spending all of our time trying to
improve that's not over all the time we
would spend trying to improve HTTP
fetching is going into HTTP client we do
do other things besides that deal but I
think that was a blight yes you have a
question in chat just just like speak to
us and we'll repeat it okay the Wi-Fi
manager is pretty basic and I haven't
seen any changes since cupcake are there
any performance design reasons that the
API doesn't expose the entire weekend
packet for us to course okay hopefully
you guys like we're able to hear that
okay I'll repeat it on the Wi-Fi manager
is pretty basic it hasn't changed since
cupcake is there any reason that we
don't expose the entire beacon packet
good question I don't think any of us
actually can give you a good answer that
because that's more of a question for
the framework engineers that's a why is
things the way they are rather than a
how do I work around this um we could
probably you know we could actually that
one I'm not sure we could give you a
workaround for but uh as far as the
reasoning things are the way
our that's for the question you want to
ask people who wrote it which none of
whom are in this room unfortunately i
will say that a log the Wi-Fi stuff
there is not used regularly by
application developers so it's possible
as an oversight or it's possible just
nobody got around to it because it's not
a priority if these are things you want
to see my usual advice is to go to be
android com which is our bug tracker do
a search see if you can find your issue
most likely it's there and then starve
it so stars are used as a measure of
votes for issues the more something gets
tarred the closer to the top of the list
and the more likely it is 70 will see it
and spend some time on it and as much as
I always hate to say this patches are
walking as well right okay any other
comments no what is the recommended
workflow with a whim that we did mean
move here no it's possible young cash
okay sorry we're and things move around
so what is the recommended workflow with
regard to current previous platform bugs
is it more effective to code blind and
deal with any issues that pop up one by
one or better to compile a list of the
most common issues and design around
them from the start I would say a coding
blind would be the wrong approach but
the thing you have to watch out for is
not so much current or previous bugs
it's that its new functionality that's
been introduced in various versions of
Android and making sure that if you use
those new versions that device is
running older versions of Android still
function and don't just crash because
the class they tried to access doesn't
exist so we have a we have an Android
training course on this I believe we do
but a even barring that I mean the most
important things to be aware when these
are happening right yeah so you have two
tools you can fiddle for that and if you
so at least if you know these issues are
there then you can go and try and salt
fix them first one is just to go and
look in the API documentation every
method is labeled with what API version
it was introduced in if you try and
just you know be sure when you use
something that it is available on
whatever API version uses your minimum
and if it's not be aware that you'll
have to write some compatibility code in
there now the other option two is to use
lint which was recently introduced as
part of the SDK tools and in most IDEs
will go in pop up a warning whenever you
do something that looks suspicious and
one of those things that it considered
suspicious is using api's that aren't
available on our target of alternative
platform versions without something that
appears to be some code to handle that
are surrounding it alrighty nor does it
detective of nematic later you have to
put a suppress warning oh yeah that's a
suppressant a warning okay so yes so you
use it it'll warn you and then you
suppress that warning to sit to
basically acknowledge that you've added
compatibility code around it great okay
our next question I recently published
an app to Google Play and it has been
doing well with good feedback I'm new to
app dev application development so on
Korea stuff about the next step how can
i bring this to google's attention for
possible promotion or pics thanks write
a review so the the show we just talked
about every friday it's at 1pm pacific
for regular apps and 2pm four games and
there's a moderator queue so just go
ahead and submit your app as an entry on
that moderator queue people will vote it
up and down to get it into our attention
or just to get it onto the show rather
even if it doesn't necessarily make it
out of the show we might still look at
it it's just a good way to go and get it
in front of our eyes I'm not going to
say that's the only way to get things
feature because it's definitely not
basically you know we go and take a look
and market see what's trending you know
we just listen around see what user of
you say so it's very much an organic
process just have a good app and
assuming it gets enough attention from
users will probably notice that
eventually but if you do want to go and
try and you're a short circuit that
approach the Friday review is a good way
to go and explicitly bring something to
our attention okay any other ideas I
just want to throw in real quick that
the Friday review is it's a great thing
to put your app through but they they
are honest
so you have to be you have to have to be
a little bit brave or you have to be
like confident in your application
because they'll they will on-air tell
you all the things that they feel I
could you could improve within your app
in terms of like you want and and stuff
like that so but most important things
make sure that you do not have the
buttons of shame because we see that
again and again so if you don't know
what the button of shame is if you run a
app targeting pre ice cream sandwich on
an Ice Cream Sandwich device that does
not have a hardware menu button we make
a software menu button appear and it's a
rather jarring experience because if you
haven't used ice cream sandwich yet
you'd know that the menu button is
essentially deprecated in favor of the
action of our overflow menu the API
looks exactly the same is just a matter
of how its displayed to the user and
solving it in most cases is just as
simple as setting target SDK equals 14
or above but we see a lot of developers
who haven't done that yet and though
pointed out to end the radicular you on
the air for having this button so to fix
that first another thing too is make
sure your app runs on phones and tablets
and provides a really good experience on
both you know android doesn't really
make a distinction between phones and
tablets especially now that we've semi
deprecated screen buckets and move to
the smallest with designators and so
what that means is basically your app
needs to run everywhere and if you don't
disappoint against you okay great thank
you next question is how can I have a
good view of the fixed number of rows of
equal height and have them fill the
screen I always have fixed number of
rows and columns I would like them to
occupy the rest of the parent layout I'd
like to use adapters I'm just ring up
the question here except just right so
it's a column view and fixed number of
used all equal height oh it says review
with fixed number of rows of equal
height okay and have them fill the
screen yes and he wants them to occupy
the rest of the parent left I'm not sure
what that means yeah
I would just say um let's look at the
first question how can I have a great
view the fixed number of rows of equal
height and have it so that they that
this set of rows fills the screen for a
number of rows whatever like four so I
think in that case it's just a matter of
you can set the grid view itself to go
and fill parents but I assume you want
to go and evenly arrange the rows or do
you want to go and have them have a
fixed height I assuming you want to go
and dynamically adjust them you know it
almost sounds into this is no list view
it's just a static grid view right so it
looks like using a doctor though so it's
got to be tied to a list view right I
yeah I'm assuming that he's got rows of
equal that no matter what number of rows
they are they should all be of the same
height and they should all you know
whatever Rosie displays they should the
some of them should fill the screen and
that the columns are always of equal
width yeah i'm not sure i haven't an
answer to this off the top of my head
just because i'm having trouble
understanding exactly what you're trying
to do if you happen to be on live please
jump on the authors to ask you some more
questions let's take a look at the stack
overflow yes all right so here's here's
the question okay so let's take a look
at your stack of letting the stack
overflow question I have a few views
that I have to place in a four by six
grid each of the view should have the
same width and the same height and fill
the screen what I want to use this grid
layout a gridview to draw them I know
that I can use a stretch mode in grid
view which sets equal with each of its
children I want to also use it to set
equal height and fill the screen
vertically can I achieve this by using
many of grid view or if not possible
then grid layout I'm looking for grid
view before switching tool in our yard
layouts and using weights because I have
uses the grid items and i would love to
use adapters rather than coding for each
element okay well first thing trying to
avoid using linear lab if you can you
can usually pull off the same thing with
relative layout right better performance
now as far as the rest of your question
I'm going to be honest I actually don't
know because this is not something that
is really one of my specialties if Roman
was on the air I totally asked him and
he probably have the answer right at the
top of his head does anybody else in the
room happen to know how did it go and
pull us off the top of their head I
would say that if you've got a fix grid
with it where you know the number of
rows and columns um i would use table
layout myself yeah i don't click grid
layout is the right yeah cool ism well
except you said he wanted to use
adapters I don't think you can with
table layout that is probably why right
he's working off this approach but i
don't i'm not experienced enough at
manipulating grid layout or to say or
grid view i mean ah yeah so I think my
guess is you probably gonna have to look
at a different at a different approach
to it doesn't seem to me like reveal
lets you have that fine-grained control
of I want the Rose to me you know this
tall and only for that tall and you're
gonna have to make dynamic adjustments
for that anyway because of screen sizes
because you can't assume a fixed screen
you know height for example so I'm not
sure what you're trying to do is going
to fit that you might have to you know
except some amount of space above or
below in order to deal with that now you
always could go and modify grid layout
yeah Gridley a good view they're both
open source so you can either just go
and subclass them if that gives you the
functionality you want or just go and
grab the source wholesale and go and
make your own copy that gives you the
behavior that you want so that's always
an option
and might not be a bad one in this case
I'm just waiting for somebody to go and
hop on there and tell me I'm horribly
wrong here but might be the easy
solution okay um we can move on and I
think there's a question here about the
fragment API in the fragment API is
there a difference between calling get
activity fine view by ID and get you
find by ID is there a reason to use one
or the other ah get-get view fine bye as
in find my ID being called on a view yes
all right um yeah so if you do it on the
activity it'll be are all of these under
that activity but if you call it on a
view then the search will be reduced to
that view and it's children so if for
instance if you think of a list view and
you have a the name of you have the idea
of a certain text field you call it on
the list view and there's like 20 30
different possibilities for it but if
you call on a view that represents one
row in the list view then there's only
one item that can really use search with
it so it goes much faster right so it's
really a scope question right yeah right
there w becomes a scope issue my lord
activity has got multiple views it
searches all of them but if you're doing
it get view on one particular video then
it's only going to search within that
context of that view right that being
said you know a lot of times if you go
and do viewed up find my ID you are sort
of your your your bubbling up a lot of
the view details into your activity and
it makes a little bit harder to move
stuff around later if you need I can't
think of very many cases where this is
something that's a cute issue in
practice but just something to keep in
mind right the more logic about your
views you put in your activity the more
tightly coupled the two of them are okay
uh anything out there and hang out land
so it has a question about keyboards
okay okay tell them to go ahead and ask
the question will try to repeat it on
the air and get back to them well fine
yeah yeah go ahead we need to get a
screen here the ghosts and chose to half
you we used to have that and new memory
studio we don't have that yet so there's
like a laptop at the very far end of the
room and I can if I yeah I see squint I
can see that there are West over there
but we read yeah and that hasn't helped
me because I wouldn't be able to see it
even if I did squint so next question is
what keeps an app from being in the
suggested terms when typing in an apt
name into the search box of
play.google.com I don't know if we can
answer that without giving away too much
of the secret sauce of the suggested
terms yeah yeah there's nothing we
published on this and generally speaking
whenever we haven't published anything
about our search algorithm we can't tell
you anything you know just like web
search there's a lot of special sauce
that goes into it and if we tell people
people tend to game it so we generally
can't give away too much unfortunately
the short version is it should do the
right thing and it's an app developer
you shouldn't have to think about it and
if you do that's usually when we have to
go and start changing things because
people are gaming the system so there's
not really much let's just focus on
building an awesome app and the rest
will come yeah we need to definitely
write a good description you know I mean
there are some things you can do to try
and make things easier for the system to
go and find your app and index it but
don't go out of your way to and say what
can I do to try and make sure that I am
the number one results because most of
the times when you do that you know
short of making a really awesome app in
getting a lot of people to use it and
leave good reviews that's when people
start doing bad things like keyword spam
and if you want a really good way to get
banned from google play keyword spam
would be at the top of the list I would
say that if if you've got a valid
concern about an app that you think
should be there because it's an
that's germane to the suggestion to the
terms you're typing in and it's not
showing up for some reason you should
contact the people that support google
play store yes assassinate yeah that's
that way you can look at a particular
situation because from this question
it's really difficult to know um what's
going wrong on if you've got something
like an app that's a dive log and you
type in dive log and it doesn't show up
that's a valid concern it should so I
would predict that it would depending on
how you designed it so it's it's best to
contact them yeah we do offer email
support for Google Play developers so if
you go to the developer site and go to
help there's a contact us section and
there is a section to go and report
issues both in with your apps publishing
or regarding to publishing your app as
well as with the developer console and
several other categories and you can
just go ahead and open up a ticket with
us and somebody from our support team
will get back to you musi within a day
or two okay so I'll just add one thing
to that and that is the way if the
question seems to be like how can i make
my appt me one of the suggested terms
and I think the standard answer to that
is make it as awesome as you possibly
can and that's the way to get it as a
search term so i think we'll close on
that one right okay let's move on oh go
ahead um the question is can i unlock
keyboards like more locale or locale two
more locale go to unlocks locales yeah
I'm not familiar with that app so my
guess is probably not so I believe
there's some security restrictions
around what an app can do into
of enabling or disabling a keyboard for
the simple reason that somebody might
make a malicious keyboard that basically
does key logging for example so I don't
think your app can programmatically say
i want you to enable app or keyboard x
you're going to have to add the the user
is going to have to intervene in order
to say yes like maybe to do that so i
think they'd i think the general answer
that is no you can't do that I'm
actually sort of surprised to learn that
there's a way to go and modify the list
of locales as well that sort of strikes
me as a sort of thing that should be
reserved for the systems I wonder what
it is this app does I've never heard of
it before so probably worth looking at
after the show and seeing what exactly
it's doing my behavior go ahead and I
have an activity that gets passed some
extras with an intent I only want these
extras to be used once when the activity
is started by the intent and any of
subsequent operations for example in on
resume should ignore this extra is it
safe to remove something from the
intense extras okay so the question is
on he has an activity that receives an
intent in the intent are some extras and
the question is if he only wants to
process the extras once at the when the
app is first started and doesn't want to
process them again for instance a non
resume is it safe to delete the extras
from the intent it seems sort of like a
bad approach aren't actually honestly I
I don't believe it's the case that
intense are immutable but I like to
treat him that way because that's the
way they're sort of meant to be used you
construct an intent you send it that
perceives it it reads things out of it
end of life cycle so for in this case
what I probably just do us at a pool and
say you know how is this the first
launch or not and if you're in non
resume honestly you don't even need to
do that you're in on resume you're in an
entirely different method just have
different code application azon resume
replication bees on resume so like a
call
send some extras be exits and then
resumes and I don't know I'd say that
it's a little bit of confusion to me
about the question here because normally
if you get an incoming in 10 you get it
in oncreate you will get it a non create
of when your activity is first started
and you look at the extras then as well
on resume on I don't know why you would
be looking at the intent for on resume
because the system has just resumed an
activity that had already been started
so there's no real reason to go and look
at the intent again once you get the
intent and on create you should stored
away the information that you got in
Global's so that when you start up again
you can look at them on so we mean I
would think that to answer this fully
week needs have some more information
about the situation I would certainly
say that I agree with Trevor you should
not treat an intent as being mutable
it's not really designed for that so
yeah I'm kind of scratching my head
about how how this would be possible
because yet the intent shows up it
creates the Christie instance then it
goes away the intent is not persisting
unless they're talking about some kind
of broadcast receiver that one Apple is
receiving and they're receiving multiple
instances of that intent so yeah
probably gonna need some more
information we're probably now in the
realm of just speculation about what the
heck is going on and what you're trying
to do so right okay do we have more
information about it or oh they're
online they could give it no this was
amanda this is a very reserved yeah okay
so I you can clone intense and then on
you got the same extras and you could
then go in and set the extras to know
but I don't really see the reason for
doing that in most cases that we're
talking about so um I think we should
probably move on here's an interesting
question with my main player wants to
host a google i/o extended in vancouver
british columbia we filled the contact
form twice and haven't heard that what's
the process who do we contact
that's a good question i don't think any
of us know the answer off the top of her
head i suspect the processes fill out
the contact form yeah so outside of that
incident of us are actually involved in
the google google i/o planning process i
don't think any of us can actually give
you a more precise answer than that
trying to think we'll try to find out if
there's a way of dealing with this but
um I don't know offhand resolve when we
will not be able to track down someone
in mudge them and say hey someone in
that Coover really once you get back to
them we cannot mention somebody's name
and email address on there now
identities contact BBQ zecom yeah anyone
who has any questions just email bob
right as i'm saying google that does not
scale right all right unless we hate Bob
which we exactly right I would speculate
that part of the problem is that we're
we're still compiling and getting ready
for Google i/o and maybe we're just not
ready to communicate out to you guys so
i would i would wait i guess we'll we'll
see if we can find somebody who might be
able to answer that question but my
guesses are not quite ready to
communicate with you and just be a
little bit patient with us great thank
you um next question this is an
interesting one I'm suffering from app
writer's block in your experience what
are the best heuristics rules of thumb
to follow when coming up with a ideas
but anytime something he knows you and
you think man we should just write an F
but be that guy that's right it's uh
yeah just beat be that guy and they're
probably you know thousands of people
who thought the exact same thing who
weren't that guy and then they will buy
your app but that's that's the easiest
way to do it yeah um I would add that if
you're stuck for ideas for apps going on
to google play store and look at some of
the apps that are there that that would
interest you and try to without you know
obviously you can't take a look at their
code without taking a look at
try to implement them but don't post
them to the Google store on the the
great thing about that is that your then
getting practice in implementing ideas
for apps and that's part of coming up
with app ideas is first of all being
ready to tackle something quickly once
you come up with the idea and then my
own feeling about coming up with ideas
for apps is to stop thinking about them
usually you come up with good ideas when
you're doing something else I'm you as
Alex said you get annoyed with something
and say I wish there was an app for that
or you just think oh I could do a better
job of writing this app than this person
is done or you've got a specific task
that you want to do and you look out
there and nobody has done something like
that so on writers when they run into
writer's block on force themselves to
sit down and write a certain number of
words per day and if you're running into
problems with figure thinking of apps
sit down once a day and just write out
crazy apps that you might put on a phone
or that don't really make sense for a
phone and if you come up with ten ideas
and one of them is halfway decent you
made some progress I like that yeah the
other thing I'd add is if you're
suffering from this kind of thing you
know think about the stuff that excites
you one what is the thing that really
gets you going you know and then after
you'd be excited to be about and I'd say
don't limit yourself right you know if
it's like some big crazy idea that you
you know just had you know some morning
you know looking at your cereal then you
know try it do it do it do whatever you
do it really excites you and I think
that that's an easier apt to write than
something that you know your neighbor
down the street said hey I really want
to do this which really doesn't interest
to you right so find stuff that excites
you and go with it you know shoot for
the moon
okay um question go ahead go gesture
detector doesn't work with fragments how
can i detect user swipes without
viewpager ok the question was gesture
detector doesn't work with fragments how
can i detect user swipes without
viewpager I don't have an answer in for
tonight so i do not know leads dumped
hmm I didn't actually know that they
didn't work with fragments I'm surprised
by that um this sounds like a good one
for stack overflow only because I'm sure
that I i would guess that somebody's run
into this issue before and has some idea
of how to deal with it unfortunately our
UI expert is not around to help us out
answer in this moment so I think we're
gonna have to basically say hmm that's a
good question we should just remove
Romans office to this room so he's
always here right there we need a
virtual Roman Rite need to figure out
how to day to dump Roman into the rest
of us yes it's not early is it
illuminated it is BTW if i can is
photoshop skills because right he's a
lot better than i am home oh well you
don't want to see anything i create in
photoshop it looks like we will take
your word for it are there any other
questions you're almost at a time yeah
um we're almost out of time and in
addition I don't see any questions that
we have left to answer this week so
we're done in box empty I don't know
what happened let's see I'm gonna check
that we didn't have one slip in while I
wasn't looking
I'm sorry I skipped this one here I
updated my app to include support for
the galaxy note ICS which is now
characterized as a normal sized screen
SW 400 DP i'm using requires smallest
with BP equal 400m manifest but the app
is showing up for all your new devices
why is this ah I can answer that so the
answer is requires smallest with DP in
Android manifest is not yet supported by
google play one day hopefully it will be
that's the reason it was put in there
most likely but at present Google Play
does not support that attribute and on
top of that they don't have cheaper
block installations just uses it as a
hint for for markets so in the future
that will almost certainly be the way to
go and do filtering but for right now it
doesn't actually work yet and if you
look at your docs there are big warnings
in there that warned you about this so
this is pretty well documented
unfortunate have a better solution for
you other than just wait okay um if we
don't have any other questions I think
we will um take it as oh it's time to go
anyway it is right it is sorry yes right
perfect timing in that case we'll
declare success here and say goodbye and
see you next week right yes sir yes I
see everyone there you know